NONETHELESS.
>> YEAH, O OF THE REASONS WHY
THE NUMBERS ARE GOIN IN ANY PEO
SOME OF T ALL T COMPLETELY
C CONSPIRACY
THIS FROM A
RT
OHIO AT
EARING ANDHE COVID VACCINE
INYS. LISTEN.T IS I ACTUALLY
ITTED THAT'SAUSING
ALL OF THESEHI
IS IT A COMBIN
PRW WE'RE FINDING
HAS A METAL ATTACHED?
I'M SURE YOU HAVEN
PICTURES OF THE INTERNET
ON THEIR FOREHEAAN
THEY CAN STICK.
GOING TO DO A EN.I'M FULLY ED.
NO, NOIC.
DOCTOR USEDY EORY TE AGAINST
MAKE  THIS?TO ALLOW OINATIO OF
>> I'M NEVERNG TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND TS,I MEAN, YOKNOW, I
THIS PANDEMIC, THESE TYPES OF
CONSPIRACY MEAN YOU
AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT IN .
THINGS IN ORDE S
SOMETHING.
SHE HAS A BOOK JUST SAY NO TO
CC'SIDCEF THIS AND
LET'S NOCATE.THERE IS NO MIP OR
ACKING DEVICORE  O
T THAT'S ATTACHE
THESE VAES
YOU KNOW, ITHARMFUL WHENOVERALL
PROB PNG TO AN
AUDI THAALF
BELIEVESHA.
MFULMENT TAKE A
LOOK AINE ACCEPTANCE IN
THFIND THIS DATANT.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A IE BEGINNI
T O AR
SAYING, YE I'LIT.
I'VEDY GOTTEN IT OR I'M IN
LINE LINE IS THA
WAIT AND SEE, THAT
MIDDLE WHICH HAS COME DOWN, ITE.
IT'S BELOW 20% BUT IT'S THE REE
T WERO
7% SAY ONLY IF R
13% THAT MAKE UPT RED LINE
SAO WAY NO HOW.TH, SOME IS BECA
CTLY PEOPLE HEARING STUFF
LIKE THAT AND, AGAINT G HOIR BU
OTHER REASON CAN'T TAKFF.EY THIA
CO-PAY OR SOMETHING INVOLVED SEL